milwaukee's is such a good team i think
the google is such a unique player
now he's talking about i want to get to
the finals so we know this young man is
going to put in the work
and do the things that's necessary to be
in that situation
giannis is that type of guy he's a good
guy great culture around him he makes
the right play when you play with
somebody that is
unselfish that one doesn't care who puts
the ball in the basket that's a recipe
for success
the bucks advance to the second round of
the nba playoffs
let's be realistic nobody's close to
milwaukee in eastern conference
milwaukee is about far and away the best
team in the eastern country
by far
the expectations are higher everyone
expects this team to have great success
like i cannot think about the finals i
got to think about the next game
you know i got to think about like what
i do right now so the bucks
lead it two to nothing the one thing
about milwaukee
they got guys who can score we know that
kawhi leonard can score
we're not getting nothing out of ibaka
or kyle lowry
we're going back to toronto that's the
only positive thing
when you take your put off the gas or
you take that mental break
that's when all the bad habits start
creeping in so if you are milwaukee
you're gonna have to change something
and the first time all year they've lost
three games in a row
this is the championship moment this is
what it's made of
this would be exciting game six is their
game seven
they got to be all in all hands on deck
because they're
not going to come and win the game seven
of milwaukee this is i think the type of
series that's going to make giannis
become a better basketball gamer it's
going to be humbling because he's going
to say we lost that series and a lot of
the losses come down to me
you shared a moment with giannis into
the kung fu what did you have to say to
him just told him congratulations he got
he got a lot better
and just to keep working sometimes it
takes experience i'm wondering if now
that you have some of that experience
you see more validity to that point or
what you think about that now that
you've gone through it
there's a lot of disappointment right
now but they're best basketball i think
with middleton and giannis is still
ahead of them the 2019 kia
nba most valuable valuable player goes
to
giannis
[Applause]
i don't think i think the front office
the ownership for
you know believing in me every time i
step on the floor
i always think about my dad and that
motivates me and he pushed me to
you know play harder my goal is to win a
championship and we're gonna do whatever
it takes to make that happen
he still has room to grow and you'll see
him continue to flourish
you saw it last year in the playoffs
they were right there
the path could be clearer now kawhi
leonard has now left the eastern
conference
now i kind of know who i am
i know what i got to do to help my team
win he's more
focused more determined more mature
but that failure that summer of
everybody laughing at him
i feel him to be where he is today went
to the playoffs you know
i wasn't able to go through toronto and
make it to the piles but
you know we learned from that we just
got to get a little bit better each year
he's improved he's not the same guy you
look at his numbers across the board
he took that loss personally and he is
bawling right now he is the best
basketball player
not just the eastern conference in the
entire world
sometimes i put a lot of pressure on
myself for me there's nobody that can
put more pressure
than myself it's now won
18 games in a row 18 straight victories
and this team has room for improvement
that's the scary thought about it
you can't guard him with one defender
so if he's surrounded with shooters
somebody has to come and he can make the
right pass with the left
or the right hand and he has the court
vision to make the right play get to the
basket or score
pass
[Music]
this was a measuring stick for them
i can't see anyone beating this team in
east unless there's an injury to them
and they just keep ascending they're not
taking their foot off the gas
if the milwaukee bucks finish regular
season with the best record
and he keeps putting up the numbers here
he's going to be mvp how can you not
give it to him when he has the best
record
and he doesn't have another superstar
giannis is mvp right now i agree what's
impressive about him is
every year he's gotten better i think
right now they've been consistent all
year they have to be the favorite coming
out of the houston conference
he's the mvp right now and the
consistency that they're playing with
right now milwaukee is the dominant team
in the east
and you have to give giannis a lot of
credit for that i kind of know my
weaknesses
if i didn't know my weakness i'd be
terrified like a guy
that don't stop at all doesn't matter if
he needs a shot he's just going to keep
coming all night
[Music]
in order for them to win the game
against us they're gonna come and hit me
they're gonna try to knock me down the
floor
i don't really care whatever they say
walking up got one guy
playing two nights there's something
going on this is the first
losing streak they've experienced this
season just hit a little roadblock and
it happens but then if it's going to
happen let's get it out the way now
they're just not focusing relax a days
all that time
there's a lot of mileage on giannis i
mean you you
lost your back court and you're
struggling a little bit
and everybody just back up and he's
bringing the ball from the top of the
key
evangenzo hits the deck they get it
inside
double team will fire it up anyway they
either need to show them that they can
compete
or that we're better than you tonight
milwaukee try to prove something
it's a big game james goes inside
with authority
james inside banks that one in
the bucks lose for the tenth time this
season
this is um a different world that we're
living in now uh the world as we know it
here in the nba has officially changed
right now
this is obviously a story that has been
on the minds of everyone
taking fans out of the arena the nba has
responded
the nba season following tonight's
action has officially been suspended for
the time
this plague of racism which comes at the
same time as this
pandemic demands our attention the scab
of racism being obviously seen
we all want to share what we are feeling
inside
at a time like this i'm encouraged that
everyone now sees
systematic racism that has been apparent
to us for a long time
it's official july 30th in orlando in a
bubble
there will be 22 teams we'll start to
get there a couple of weeks before
so what are some of the issues what
scared me about the guys going back to
play is injuries
you know these these injuries that you
do not have enough time to really get
over when i think about the milwaukee
bucks that was one of the questions that
we all had was
how can they perform in the playoffs
without when giannis take a break
boston is good but you're not with fear
like you don't put like when you see
that greek boy coming
we gotta keep doing gotta keep getting
better we gotta stay humble and it's a
long journey
it's a long journey
you